i know that some architects say that the  software is just an extension  of your pencil but i really think that  the infinite amount of 3d modeling  possibilities in rhino has really helped  me in the creative process  and it's helped me design geometries  that probably would have taken me a  very long time to figure out by hand  or on autocad for example this project  i wanted to create a torquing motion  throughout the building and i just  started with a couple of sketch models  sketched out the plans and i just moved  straight into rhino because  i could quickly iterate through a bunch  of options and geometries  and i knew it was going to take me  forever to figure it out on paper